the Arctic is phenomenal it's modern
it's intellectually challenging imagine
for the first time in human history a
whole new ocean is opening up for human
traffic this has never happened in the
history of man but it's happening now as
the Arctic Ocean is opening the ice is
diminishing and this of course is
closely connected to climate change so
here is a double challenge that we have
to face that we have to come to terms
with and that we have to understand also
as the opportunity that it also is and
as a Dane as somebody from Denmark as a
journalist trying to understand these
processes there is a double challenge
involved because we also have to come to
terms with our history as a colonial
power in Greenland we have to understand
on the one side our affection our love
our fascination with the Arctic we're
not physically connected but we are
historically culturally connected to the
Arctic and then on the other side there
is the people of Greenland a majority of
whom wants to form their own state they
want to be independent from us so we
have to grapple with this duality in our
life with the Arctic